merci monsieur le président monsieur
cadrage général j'ai l'honneur de
présenter la locution préenregistrés de
son excellence monsieur hassan rohani
président de la république islamique à
dire on au nom d'allah le clément le
miséricordieux louanges à lui tout
puissant que la paix et le salut soit
sur le prophète jeu monsieur le
président je suis fier de vous présenter
vos félicitations vous qui représentez
notre voisin fraternelle la turquie vous
venez d'être élu président à la 115e
session de l'assemblée générale
et c'est bien mérité je ne joue en
profite pour vous souhaiter tout succès
ainsi qu'au secrétaire général et à tous
vos collègues afin que tous les
objectifs de l'onu soient accomplis
excellence les peuples du monde
prenaient pour acquis les bienfaits de
la santé et la sécurité
ils ont été surpris par la flambée de
kovy de 19
pourtant minuscule le virus de lakovic
19 a réussi à secouer si gravement les
fondements de la gestion mondiale et de
la gouvernance nationale que la
principale assemblée du monde se réunit
aujourd'hui par vidéoconférence
l'aco ville de 19 et la sphère de toute
l'humanité
étant donné la croissance rapide de la
science de la technologie et des médias
une affaire commune donc qui nous montre
que malgré tous les progrès l'ignorance
humaine dépasse largement l'étendue des
connaissances lakovic 19 nous rappelle à
notre devoir d'humilité face au tout
puissant et à la vérité de la création
la maladie semble montrer la voie aux
sociétés vers la piété civile dans la
promotion de l'éthique sociale et
individuelle ainsi que l'inciter à
prévenir la détérioration de
l'environnement et de la manipulation de
la nature ainsi que l'intervention sans
limite dans la création
c'est une peste universelle qui se joue
des frontières artificielles de la
puissance et de la santé et de la
richesse elle me rappelle que en tant
que membre de l'humanité nous ne
saurions faire face aux problèmes
mondiaux
si le nous y mettons balle tous ensemble
dans le monde entier les temps sont durs
dans cette pandémie
pourtant mon pays le peuple résilient de
léran au lieu de pouvoir jouir d'une de
partenariat ou de coopération mondiale
il est aux prises avec les plus graves
sanctions de son histoire imposé au
mépris repris flagrant de la charte des
nations unies des accords internationaux
et de la résolution 22 31 du conseil de
sécurité
mesdames et messieurs la vidéo qu'a vu
le monde entier et qui montrait le
traitement que la police des états unis
est réservé est un homme afro américain
a fait écho à notre propre expérience
nous avons les premiers coups des airs
connus dans ce pied posé sur la nuque
l'arrogance qui foulait les nations
indépendantes
pendant deux décennies le vaillant
peuple iranien a payé lui aussi du prix
fort sa quête de liberté
face à la domination et au despotisme et
pourtant la nation iranienne n'a pas
fait que résister à cette pression est
la même prospérer tout en cherchant à
accomplir son rôle historique et
civilisationnelle dax de paix et de
stabilité de héros du dialogue et de la
tolérance de champion de la lutte contre
l'occupation et l'extrémisme
nous sommes tenus aux côtés du peuple
afghan contre l'occupant soviétique
contre les seigneurs de la guerre locaux
contre les extrémistes contre les
terroristes d'al-qaïda et contre
l'occupant américain
nous avons joué un rôle central devant
tous les processus de paix et de
réconciliation
à commencer par la conférence de bonn en
2001 ou encore des initiatives
régionales au milieu des années 80 nous
avions demandé des accords de sécurité
collectif dans le golfe persique
alors que les pouvoirs régionaux et
mondiaux faisait front derrière cela
derrière saddam hussein et sa guerre des
prix pétroliers en 2013 nous avons
proposé la résolution consacrée à un
monde contre la violence et l'extrémisme
dit aussi wave résolution sera adoptée à
l'unanimité par la présente assemblée
l'an 2018 nous avons proposé un pacte de
non-agression à nos voisins et en 2019
nous avons présenté l'initiative up à
savoir initiative initiative de paix
d'ormuz que nous avons donc présenté à
l'assemblée générale
dans le souci d'améliorer les
perspectives de paix et de stabilité
dans le golfe persique
nous avons été le premier pays de la
région qui se soit tenue aux côtés du
peuple du koweït et à le défendre contre
l'occupation par saddam c'est bien
l'iran qui a mis à bas ces rêves des
domination sur ses anciens alliés arabes
nous avons défendu le peuple iranien
contre la tyrannie de saddam contre
l'occupation des états unis et contre la
sauvagerie de dèche
nous avons appuyé tous les irakiens
kurdes ou arabes sunnites ou chiites
yazidi aux chrétiens et nous avons
accompagné le peuple irakien dans tous
ses progrès démocratiques ego lancée par
le conseil de gouverneurs
en 2003 et on continue avec tous les
gouvernement démocratiquement élu depuis
nous nous sommes tenus aux côtés du
peuple syrien que nous avons défendu
contre des dizaines de groupes takfiris
terroristes de séparatistes et de
combattants étrangers nous avons
présenté un plan en quatre points centré
sur l'autodétermination du peuple syrien
en 2013 alors que d'autres recherches
est une solution militaire en 2016
nous avons formé le processus d'un stade
en partenariat avec la russie et la
turquie processus qui visait à obtenir
la paix la stabilité politique en syrie
nous avons défendu le poc le
gouvernement libanais contre l'occupant
sioniste contre les va-t-en-guerre dans
la propre sang et contre les
conspirateurs étrangers
jamais nous n'avons fermé les yeux sur
l'occupation sur le génocide sur les
déplacements forcés sur le racisme en
palestine
jamais nous n'avons pactiser sur la
ville sainte d'al qods ni sur les droits
fondamentaux du peuple palestinien en
2012 nous avons présenté une solution
démocratique et qui passerait par le
référendum en palestine nous avons
vigoureusement demandé que justice soit
rendue aux victimes d'agressions dans le
peuple
dix militaires assiégés nous avons
présenté un plan de paix en quatre
points dès le début des hostilités en
nous avons lutter seul contre les
extrémistes et les terroristes de doges
ce même qui prétendait lutter pour
l'islam dont
une région sensible du monde la
communauté internationale devait en
effet pouvoir voir le véritable visage
de l'islam l'islam modéré rationnelle et
non pas l'extrémisme et la démagogie mme
notre héros assassiné le général martyrs
sont les manies et l étendard de la
lutte contre l'extrémisme violent au
moyen orient il a lutté pour protéger
tous les citoyens de la région laïcs ou
religieux musulmans chrétiens chiites ou
sunnites contre les obscurantistes
médiévaux en 2015
nous sommes parvenus à signer le plan
d'action global commun l'un des plus
grands succès diplomatiques de
l'histoire nous y restons fidèles et ce
malgré les violations persistantes que
commettent les états unis monsieur le
président dans un tel pays ne mérite pas
d'être sanctionné on ne rétribuent pas
la paix par la guerre on ne récompense
pas la lutte contre l'extrémisme par des
assassinats
on ne réagit pas au peuple voit son
choix exprimé par les urnes en iran en
irak au liban par les agitations
extérieur ni par l'appui à des processus
non démocratique aux émeutes
ne nous arrêtons pas au mollet sont les
faits par les parents eux mêmes ils nous
disent qu'ils sont venus dans la région
pour lutter contre saddam hussein
monstre qu'ils avaient eux mêmes créé
nourris sinon c'est dans sa guerre
contre l'iran qu'ils avaient équipé
d'armes chimiques et des machines de
guerre les plus sophistiqués ils
prétendent lutter contre le terrorisme
et contre daraîche alors que ce sont eux
mêmes qui ont créé ce réseau terroriste
ils ont même le front d'attendre l'arrêt
gratitude régional en retour ils nous
accusent sans aucun fondement de tenter
de nous doter de l'armé nucléaire
il impose des sanctions sous le prétexte
de la prolifération nucléaire
et ce alors même que ce sont eux qui
porte l infamie d'avoir été les seuls à
utiliser
l'arme atomique dans l'histoire de
l'humanité et ce alors même que le seul
détenteur de l'armé nucléaire en asie
occidentale mène le manège de la non
prolifération
ils n'ont que les droits de l'homme à la
bouche mais par la politique de pression
maximale
ils ont porté atteinte à la santé et au
bien-être et même au droit à la vie de
tous les iraniens
ils sont les mains directement plongé
avec leurs complices et régionaux dans
tous les cas d'occupation de guerre
d'agression la palestine l'afghanistan
le yémen la syrie l'irak le liban la
libye le soudan la somalie et c'est
pourtant l'iran qu'ils accusent de leur
défaite pourtant inévitable face à la
volonté des peuples de la région
ils ont vendu
des armes pour des centaines de
milliards de dollars à leurs clients de
la région et ils ont fait de cette
région une poudrière
et pourtant il tente de priver l'iran de
ses exigences minimales de sécurité et
méprisent le droit international et le
consensus mondial en cherchant à étendre
les restrictions à l'armement contre
l'iran au mépris de la lettre même de la
résolution 22,31 du conseil de sécurité
je tiens ici à remercier les présidents
du conseil de sécurité des mois d'août
et de septembre 2009 1 je remercie
également 13 des membres du conseil en
particulier la russie et la chine qui
par deux fois ont opposé un non décisive
et sonore aux tentatives illicite de
l'onu qui cherchent à exploiter de
concert ces résolutions dans tout rompre
cette victoire n'appartient pas qu'à
l'iran c'est la victoire de toute la
communauté mondiale
en cette période d'autres international
de transition dans vers un monde post
occidental on voit en effet qu'en
prétendant à l'hégémonie 6010 en
s'enfermant tout seul dans l'isolément
mesdames et messieurs où at on vu de
précédents à ces actes d'un gouvernement
qui renie son raison aucune le résultat
de 13 ans de négociations multilatérales
négociations auxquelles son prédécesseur
avait participé qui violent toute honte
bue les résolutions du conseil
international et qui punit les autres de
respecter ces mêmes résolutions
où at on vu qu'un état de ce genre
prétendent en même temps cherché des
négociations cherche imposer un grand
accord les états unis ne peuvent nous
imposer ni les négociations ni la guerre
la vie est certes difficile sous ces
sanctions pourtant nous aurons bien plus
lieu de nous plaindre de la vie sans
l'indépendance la liberté politique chez
nous est essentiel à nos yeux nous
sommes la plus vieille démocratie du
moyen-orient
notre peuple détermine son propre destin
et ne les changera pas sa liberté contre
les ingérences étrangères
la démocratie y relève du droit
souverain des pays elle ne serait prêté
le flanc à l'ingérence des des étrangers
encore moins un étranger terroristes et
interventionniste et qui reste aux
prises avec ses illusions du 19 août
1953 lorsque ses prédécesseurs avaient
renversé la seule démocratie du
moyen-orient par un coup d'état
la dignité la prospérité de notre pays
voilà l'essentiel pour nous est le seul
moyen de l'obtenir c'est une diplomatie
reposant sur la volonté nationale et sur
sa résine la résilience du pays nous
ne sommes pas des jetons dans la
négociation interne américaine dans ces
élections ou dans sa politique interne
tout gouvernement américain après les
prochaines élections devra s'en remettre
à l'évidence de la résilience du peuple
iranien le monde doit aujourd'hui
refuser le harcèlement et l'arrogance à
l'aise de la domination de l'hégémonie
et bientôt sur année nos nations nos
enfants doivent voir un monde meilleur
plus sûr fondée sur l'état de droit
c'est maintenant que nous pouvons faire
le bon choix
je vous remercie de votre attention